[Music]
so the Brazilian agency of international
tourism promotion Jesus Hey
they [ __ ] up and they actually shared
this image here on their story and I
will read it to you it's a script what
is that
this was posted by someone else and it
says Rio is such a beautiful city but
beautiful is not enough I just spent
three days in Rio with my family and in
those three days my family and I were
robbed and my 9 year old sister
witnessed a violent robbery I can't
recommend a visit to a city where I felt
afraid of even leaving the apartment
hopefully things will get better in the
future and locals and tourists will be
able to enjoy the beauty Rio has to
offer and they they location tagged it
Rio de Janeiro we blame the victim what
if they were wearing LV print everything
and they had like a LV luggage so of
course certainly a robbed yeah you
weren't Balenciaga have some [ __ ] yeah
that's so true because in a hundred and
twenty thousand five hundred muggings
last year alone every single one of them
was wearing designer friends really
every single one you're right saying who
should blame all these victims I don't
wanna play mall the victims but then
some victims I'm like you know better
you shouldn't have yeah one of my
favorite genres of youtube is shoot out
videos and I just love Steve's face
right after you said that he's like [ __ ]
we're in that video I always you know
it's always a dot dot dot on my head I'm
like I can't wait for what he's about
I've never seen that job I've seen like
sports and entertainment I've ever seen
shootouts
the beauty of this man is that you don't
know where the joke is going and it's
not a joke ever why the [ __ ] are you
smiling let me finish my story god damn
it are you like what I said that was
funny
yes exactly but to us it's a joke to him
it's the truth
so you know one of my passionate of
shootout videos a lot of them come from
Rio de Janeiro a lot of them come from
Brazil mm-hmm and you can see people
they'll come up to you on scooters and
hold you up at gunpoint
I saw one world was like a guy is riding
the scooter and another guy comes up
holds him up at gunpoint there's a
policeman in a taxicab that gets out and
he shoots the guy that has the robber
that has another guy on gunpoint oh I
saw one where a chick who's leaving a
store she's a she's about to get
abducted and then she pulls a [ __ ]
gun out and blow the guy who I see now
on - Wow
I used to work at Carmack's I remember I
had this chick come in she was getting a
car looked at I think she was trying to
appraise it so she could sell it she had
been in the States for a couple months
and she was like she was desperately
looking for a husband because she did
not want to go back to Brazil that's
like kidnapping you think kidnapping is
like just reserved for kids but like
adults get kidnapped a lot in Brazil
especially in actual slavery that that
will out that - but if they if the
robbers think that they come from a
wealthy family or that that money they
will hold the grown-ups for ransom each
day more than likely still kill them it
is [ __ ] ridiculous the stories that
she was telling me at me like cuz you
fear Brazil you black o big booty women
was pappadimos on earth have you ever
seen cydia god no I was a baby made me
never want to go to Brazil there's seven
year old bugs can you imagine a seven
year old dog okay so with the gun that
changes is but it's irregular sever you
I will push the [ __ ] out of a
seven-year-old it's not even like the
hole with the back of the heel like what
did you say like but what a gun is like
hey I'm sorry sir I rather get robbed by
a 50 year old than an 8 year old because
the 8 year old will kill me
ya have no conscience yes no [ __ ] no
you can't reason with them they don't
really think that they're gonna live
forever like anyone under like 16 I am
[ __ ] scared if they're like oh I feel
like I might be a
mesmerism like I know a couple coin
tricks oh oh I can pull a quarter out of
the air you see that dude that's what's
so funny about our movies and [ __ ] we
see a little kid gangster in a movie
where happened over there they're
probably just like what's funny they're
saying that there were four thousand
murders last year - in real yeah in Rio
but they're saying that this that the
homicide rate is the lowest since
records began in 1991 Jesus so that's
what they're so they were keeping
records in the 90s like just like ninety
ten there's like yours and a lot of
[ __ ] that is not recording this
but yes so they're 89 they're like hey
Louise record all these murders and [ __ ]
like come on it's not that many double
ninety-nine is like I you know the next
year they're all sitting there at the
meeting and then you might have been
known as something rap yeah wasn't a
great year you're right but yeah so
they're assuming here that the the
mistake happened because whoever was in
charge of the Tourism Board socialist
like social media they probably didn't
understand English that well so they
thought because the word beautiful isn't
it it's finally it's off with Rio such a
beautiful city you know yeah what's
wrong with using the word beautiful
no no listening I was listening no that
was Louis County his [ __ ] macros for
more people to come to their country
yeah so what she's saying is they saw
someone tweet something out or not sweet
but Instagram or whatever or something
out about Rio right
but the person is in charge of the
Tourism Board social media thing account
I guess they don't know English that
well so all they I guess understood was
that Rio de Janeiro is beautiful without
really seeing what this whole story is
bad the advertisement worked on them and
it worked on birth I want to go and
watch the crime oh [ __ ] in a safety
bubble perhaps yes I picture me on a
back of a pickup truck with the machine
gun and with like the real police but
you're causing the trouble you're like
hey you better commit a crime yeah it's
like a safari adventure Oh No urban
urban safari adventure yeah yeah yeah
but then I don't know yeah maybe maybe I
didn't think it through but then if they
see the police there they're not gonna
do the crime and also you're probably
picturing adults like a lot of this
might be kids and [ __ ] in here and be
like oh I want to see this if it's a kid
stick I don't see it I'll grab the gun
away from him slap have you ever tried
to grab a loaded gun for somebody nobody
have you there if their kid and they're
not looking my way I'm more likely to
kick the [ __ ] out of them okay cuz I
feel like I'll be able to kick them and
they'll fly and I could grab the gun
what do you think you are huh what do
you think Jason Bourne never did leave
Jesus Christ it's boy but if I'm you
gonna do drop mine another man in your
old I'll kick the [ __ ] out of that for
you think though I'll kick that well
like leonidas did the Persians I'll
[ __ ] this is sparta [ __ ]
[Laughter]
from the back of course he's not
pointing the gun at me
no candy you [ __ ] punt a kid and
you're like now that's real football
so you wrestled the gun out of someone
no close calls working at the jail
system no no no no close calls with jail
with his skin was one time where
somebody I so like one time I was I was
teaching them one in the barracks and
they had to sign out to those restaurant
because you have to have an account any
time in maintenance not where they're
supposed to be so I also had a TA in the
TA is up there inmates too but they we
call them white shirts because they wear
all white just so we be easily
identified from for the teachers and for
the sheriff so they're like good
behavior yeah okay that one I had a
clock on his desk that went on a wall
and because he was keeping track of time
and just keeping us on task but there
was another random clock in the room so
the TI got up to pass all papers and
when the guy came up to use the restroom
he saw the clock he took the battery out
of the clock right so the TA said back
down he even really paying attention to
it and then he realized I guess that the
clock wasn't counting anymore and that's
when he had let me know that the battery
is missing so I axe everybody in the
room but nobody knew anything had to go
get the sheriff
and they basically locked down the whole
facilitating keister the batteries
battery well what it is is they take the
batteries and they use them in the
homemade tattoo guns that they make and
so tattooing is illegal darling that
type of stuff so yeah they can just get
a return just go on Amazon get it yeah
why don't we just get a solar panel TIFF
yes get a solar panel yeah we would
happen they had a lot the whole thing
that lock the whole thing down with
- dadadada it makes away in my class
what - all their barracks toss
everything flipped everything and to do
who admitted to having it they threw him
in the hole for like a week now back to
Jos question did a jury confinement for
a week Oh question yes the question was
did you get into a fight or a digit that
wasn't your question we said we're
without the other question here took it
back he when he went to the bathroom he
took it back to his dorm there were
multiple facilities at this jail they
had like they had like one one was like
they stayed in barracks and it was kind
of like an army looking very type thing
that there was like another facility or
talk called the belly of the beast and
that was like north that's a big
facility they have like different levels
to it and then there was this other
place I liked this facility was called
south and I called that what dreams go
to die because like it was always colder
there I felt like this the air is
heavier and it was just it was different
when he's no longer the whole was in
North so North is the big facility north
was the one it had been known like
locked up and they use it for NCIS and
CIA's like they use that facility a lot
of filming goes on out I think of the
whole as a method for punishing inmates
you think it's humane um I think it's
very difficult to like straddle the line
and always be humane and in good
standing when it comes to disciplining
of like rapists and convicted criminals
it's not like I don't think that the
recidivism is the rate at which people
return but jail the recidivism rates
like 70 something yeah they love jail
huh well I mean the food is three meals
a day but it's very difficult to also to
like reprogram somebody when once
they're in their 30s right especially
when they're getting released and they
don't have everything they need all the
necessary tools to be successful and
also if you're not gonna release them
and they put them in like a halfway
house that is completely away from the
environment that they were picked up in
they are more than likely to just go
back to the crimes that they were doing
because there's still
that same environment so unless you're
moving them to a different area and
giving them the necessary tools to be an
active member of society a functioning
member of society an upstanding member
of society they are more than likely
gonna end back in jail one guy got
released at 8:00 in the morning was back
in jail by 7:00 p.m. that night they
didn't even get a chance to give
somebody else's bad my coworker said he
made more money in jail than out the
only reason why he wants to stay out now
it's because he has a daughter yeah I
know some guys that have been in jail
for so long when their release date was
coming up they wanted to come back
because they hadn't I used to yeah 30
years in jails like the world is
completely changed in 30 years so that's
like a time warp they get they don't
want [ __ ] I guess they want man's but
that's that's that's the way I simplify
it
[Applause]
[Music]